am i interrupting actually I was just
about to call the children back in then
I will be very quick do you have any
plans for Saturday evening tomorrow no
not really
there's this new English novelist have
you heard of Virginia Woolf
yes my sister viola lives in England
she's a fan she just sent me some of her
short stories well Virginia Woolf is
doing a reading in Union City tomorrow
night I read about that in the paper
would you be my guest
I'm sorry I really sprung that on you
you know obviously I would love to it's
just certain shouldn't resist me over
yes yes it should um would you please do
the honors for me yeah why don't you
think about it and let me know I will
thank you okay
she'll be discussing women in publishing
right up your alley
[Music]
thank you all right everyone please take
out your workbooks turn to page nine
looks like you chopped enough wood for
two winners I guess you heard about
Elizabeth and Lucas yep it's just a
reading
I wouldn't fill it up more than that I'm
not you brought it up not me so it
doesn't bother you then no of course not
why would it bother me where you do
whatever they want or go wherever they
want you just suddenly had the urge to
chop wood what are you getting out of
here just making conversation well I'm a
little busy well fair enough
what are you doing I'm helping him why I
just suddenly have the urge to chop wood
thank you but I don't need your help
it's like I don't need people in town
walking on eggshells around me okay I'm
not making a big deal out of this
no nobody else has to well I'm gonna
help you anyway you know we can talk you
can talk loud
I don't know baseball you know I love
baseball
you love baseball too don't you I know
you do put your favorite team Tigers
ah yeah I'm a Yankee fan favorite player
mmm
Ty Cobb great player you know what
though he just doesn't have enough power
[Music]
auntie Rosie we'll be right back please
mm-hmm I need his toy toy what toy dog
dog okay oh he's tired he is rubbing his
eyes his cheeks are flush but he just
will not go down for a nap dog dog dog
IIIi can't find the dog anywhere well
it's not upstairs well when is the last
time we saw it I know we had it in town
in town did we have it on the way home
well I don't know yes
no I don't know okay I'll go I'll go
[Music]
I'm coming
[Music]